supongamos que tenemos la función efe y
que esta función es continua en el
intervalo de ahorita no le voy a poner a
y b porque esos los quiero utilizar más
adelante pero bueno a partir de esta
función efe minúscula dt vamos a
construir la función f mayúscula de x
igual a la integral a la integral que va
de c a x df minúscula de t dt muy bien
estas acá es un área verdad esto lo
estamos definiendo para las x es en el
intervalo se coma d así que si nos
tomamos una x por acá
esta función lo que nos indica es el
área que está por debajo de la curva que
está por debajo de la curva y en 13 y x
entonces esto sería f mayúscula de x
lo que platicamos en vídeos pasados es
que si efe minúscula es continua
entonces esta f mayúscula es derivable
en todo el intervalo se coma b y además
tenemos que f prima de x es igual a efe
de x vaya que esto sucede para todas las
x es en el intervalo se coma de muy bien
esto simplemente es el teorema
fundamental del cálculo lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es conectar el
primer teorema fundamental del cálculo
con el segundo teorema fundamental igual
del cálculo bueno la segunda parte como
quieras llamarle esto es lo que
utilizamos para evaluar las integrales
definidas va entonces para pensar en
esto vamos a tomar f mayúscula debe
menos f mayúscula de a efe mayúscula
para ciertos números ahí ve que quedan
en este intervalo en el intervalo se
coma d además vamos a pensar que b es
más grande que a por comodidad sale
entonces al cambiar estas f mayúsculas
por lo que le corresponde en la integral
obtenemos la integral la integral de s
ab nada más sustituimos de c a b de ft
dt - la dfa pero que se está vamos
primero con esta pues esta es nos vamos
aquí a donde estaba digamos que está por
aquí
ahí tomamos la recta vertical y lo que
estamos considerando es el área por
debajo de la curva entonces estamos
considerando esta parte de la casa le
déjame marcarla
en este color azul ok entonces esta
integral corresponde a esta área ya eso
tenemos que restarle tenemos que
restarle f mayúscula de a osea la
integral de c aa de ft dt y si nos vamos
a la figura dijimos que a es más pequeño
digamos que está por acá y entonces el
área que estamos restando es esta
muy bien entonces qué sucede si el área
azul que es la de b le restamos el área
rosa mexicano que es la dea pues
obtenemos esta área que queda en medio
verdad esta que voy a pintar con color
verde un color verde
y que está representada por la integral
de a a b de ft
dt muy bien esto de aquí está muy bueno
verdad esto es el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo lo que nos dice
lo siguiente lo que nos dice es que si f
es continua si f es continua entonces
esta expresión esta expresión esta
integral definida la podemos evaluar
tomando la anti derivada f mayúscula
quizás debería ser un poco más claro
verdad sea mira esta igualdad nos está
diciendo que f mayúscula es la anti
derivada
anti derivada
de f de ok entonces lo que nos dice el
segundo teorema fundamental del cálculo
es que esta expresión que encerré en el
recuadro
esta integral definida la podemos
evaluar considerando a efe mayúscula una
anti derivada de f y evaluando en el
extremo superior y a eso
restándole el extremo inferior va a efe
en el extremo inferior justo eso es lo
que nos dice el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo y eso es lo que
utilizamos para hacer las integrales
definidas verdad quizás aquí quedó al
revés es más déjame reescribirlo para
que quede en la forma en la que
usualmente lo utilizamos entonces nos
quedaría que la integral de a a b de ft
de t para una función continua efe
consiste en tomar una derivada f
mayúscula evaluarla en el extremo
superior y a eso restarle esa anti
derivada evaluada en el extremo inferior
ok
este es el segundo teorema fundamental
del cálculo y este teorema es
importantísimo en las clases de cálculo
porque justo a partir de esto es como
evaluamos todas nuestras integrales
definidas